escalade de violence en birmanie la
journée de samedi a été marquée par de
violents affrontements entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
depuis le début du coup d'état militaire
du 1er février un important mouvement de
contestation secoue le pays considérés
comme des actes de terrorisme par le
nouveau pouvoir
ces rassemblements sont réprimés pour
assurer le maintien de l'ordre d'après
les militaires la démocratie que nous
appelons de nos voeux deviendrait une
démocratie indisciplinés
si la loi a été violée n'étaient pas
respectées les militants opposés au
pouvoir militaire avait appelé à une
nouvelle série de manifestation ce
samedi une date particulière pour les
militaires puisqu'elle coïncide avec la
journée des forces armées chaque année
un gigantesque défilé est organisé à
cette occasion avant cette démonstration
de force
l'armée a tenu à transmettre un message
à l'attention des manifestants
retenez la leçon de ceux qui sont morts
brutalement du danger d'être frappé à
l'arrière de la tête ou dans le dos ne
mourrai pas pour rien malgré les menaces
plusieurs milliers de personnes sont une
nouvelle fois descendus dans la rue des
rassemblements violemment réprimée par
les forces de l'ordre
au point de faire de la journée de
samedi la plus sanglante depuis le début
de la contestation
une violence dénoncé par la communauté
internationale nous sommes horrifiés par
l'effusion de sang perpétré par les
forces de sécurité birmanes montrant que
la junte sacrifiera la vie du peuple
pour servir la minorité
j'adresse mes plus sincères condoléances
aux familles des victimes
le peuple courage de la birmanie rejette
le règne de terreur de l'armée à
l'occasion de la journée des forces
armées de birmanie
les forces de sécurité se sont
déshonorés en tirant sur des civils non
armés
en cette période de crise économique qu
vide et une situation humanitaire qui
s'aggrave aujourd'hui le défilé
militaire et les exécutions
extrajudiciaires en disent long sur les
priorités de la junte militaire
malgré les prises de positions et les
menaces de sanctions à l'encontre des
responsables militaires
le pouvoir en place semble décidé à
poursuivre sa politique de répression à
l'encontre des manifestants